the 74th annual Academy Awards on ABC
brought to you by Cadillac bold vehicles
defying convention Cadillac breakthrough
Morgan Stanley one passion one mission
one principle one client at a time
diet pepsi would like to remind you to
think young drink young and MasterCard
there's some things money can't buy for
everything else there's MasterCard to
present the Oscars for screenplay
Academy award-winner
Gweneth Paltrow and a nominee tonight
Ethan Hawke
in a screenplay for Sunset Boulevard
Billy Wilder observed audiences don't
know somebody sits down and writes a
picture they think the actors make it up
as they go along in case you were
wondering let's look at a part of the
process that got these movies to the
category of Best Adapted Screenplay the
nominees are
Akiva Goldsman for a beautiful mind
based on the book by Sylvia Nasar
Daniel Klaus and Terry Zwigoff forego
school based on the comic book by Daniel
Clowes rob fest injure and todd field
for in the bedroom
based on the story killings by Andre de
booth
Fran Walsh Philippa boyens and Peter
Jackson for the Lord of the Rings the
Fellowship of the Ring based on the book
by j.r.r tolkien Ted Elliott Terry
Rossio Joe Stillman and Roger SH Shulman
for Shrek based on the book by William
sty
and the Oscar goes to Akiva Goldsman
this is Akiva Goldsman first Academy
Award his other writing credits include
practical magic Boston space a time to
kill and the client this is the second
Oscar for a beautiful mind
this evening
I am terrified
I would like to thank the Academy at
Universal Ron Meyer Stacy Snyder and
Scott Stuber at DreamWorks Steven
Spielberg Jeffrey Katzenberg and David
Geffen
my agents Richard Lovett Risa Gartner
and Torey Metzger and my attorney Steve
Warren I would like to thank the film's
producers the unstoppable Brian Grazer
and the gifted Karen Kela I would like
to thank John and Alicia Nash for their
extraordinary courage and for entrusting
us with their lives I would like to
thank the dazzling Russell Crowe who is
incalculable talent and dedication are
the very life of a beautiful mind and I
would like to thank Ron Howard whose
persistence of vision an unflagging
grace are the movies soul and I'd like
and I'd like to dedicate this award to
my three parents to have Goldsman Mira
Rothenberg and Elizabeth Lee who taught
me that when understanding people who
suffer from mental illness it is good to
have a beautiful mind but a greater gift
still is to discover a beautiful heart
thank you for this
you